okay so homelander is probably the most
fascinating character in the boys
the guy always seems like he's one
second away from turning someone's rib
cage inside out
and the superman parody has a lot going
on
but who is he what are his hopes his
dreams
and why is this intro so bad well
throughout this video we're going to be
going through the character's entire
origin story in both the comics and show
as well as discussing where things in
the future could be going with him
because of this there will be heavy
spoilers so if you don't anything in the
series rune then i recommend that you
turn off now
make sure you subscribe for coverage on
the show week by week and drop a thumbs
up if you enjoy the video
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into homelander
okay so as with most of the seven the
entire backstory of homelander is a
complete fabrication
according to vault the character is
actually an alien that traveled to earth
from a dying planet
and after landing in america he was
raised by his lovely
lovely parents in a small town located
on the farm belt
here he learned the difference between
right and wrong and
i'm sure i'm sure i've heard this
somewhere before now
homelander grew up to represent truth
justice and the american way
but in reality he was just a science
experiment created by the corporation so
that they could mass market superheroes
to the public
in reality homelander alongside seven
other children
were given massive amounts of compound b
in the womb
as we know this drug was created by the
germans during the second world war
in order to make the aryan superman a
reality it was during this time that
stormfront was created
who as you know becomes a big villain in
the boys
the scientists behind the chemical fled
the country after hitler turned against
him
and thus he went to america taking
compound v
and stormfront along for the ride from
here he built ball up
until we got the mega corporation that
we see in both the show and comic book
now one of the most interesting things
about homelander is that he's actually
partly cloned from stormfront
when vault was attempting to create new
superpowered beings
he used the dna from all the heroes in
order to improve on them
so homelander already had a big chance
of turning into a psychopath
due to stormfront's nature however on
top of this
because of his exposure to countless
experimental chemicals and his
upbringing in the science lab
the character has turned into an
absolute egomaniac with poor morals
and little empathy for those around him
there was a further clone created from
his dna which we'll get into in just a
bit
but overall the character is very much a
science experiment gone wrong
in the show homelander was raised by
jonah vogelbaum
who gave him the name jon jon didn't
have a mother figure to grow towards
and thus he became attached to a female
doctor however
he accidentally hugged her too hard
which broke her spine
and thus killed her now as for his
powers homelander is pretty much a
parody of superman
and he possesses almost all of the same
abilities but none of his weaknesses
obviously the character can fly and he's
capable of moving at speeds over mach 3.
he also possesses super speed similar to
the flash and is quick enough to kill
someone
without them even knowing that he was
there the character has superhuman
strength
and because of this he can lift almost
anything
he's also completely impervious to
damage and it's difficult to physically
harm the character
in any real way whether it's bullets gas
explosions or even a nuke nothing faces
homelander
and because of this he's probably the
most invulnerable out of the seven
he also has superhuman stamina meaning
that he does not tire or feel fatigue
due to his muscles producing no lactic
acid he also has
extra vision and the massively overused
heat vision
which he pretty much uses to handle all
of his problems
and also to make to make the milk taste
even more delicious
now though he doesn't have a weakness
per se he does have an incredibly
fragile ego
in preparing for this video i watched an
interview with anthony starr who plays
the character
and he said that homeland is biggest
weakness is pretty much the view that he
has of himself
in episode 4 of season 2 we saw how
stormfront was able to use social media
to completely mess with his mind
i've actually seen the fifth episode
already and not to get too
spoilery but they do something very cool
with him which shows humanity
actually do have something that they can
use against him and that is his image
homelander wants to be loved by all but
the more that his crimes are brought to
light
the more hated he becomes and if he's
dropped by vaught
then he has nowhere to turn now if that
was to ever be the case
he would obviously go off the leash and
this is where the character black noir
comes in
we'll discuss this more in depth towards
the end of the video but noir becomes
very important now in the comics
homelander initially started out by
actually wanting to do good
however the further he caused chaos and
the more he saw that he was part of the
system
he just became and decided to enjoy what
he could
ford had powerful pr teams that would
help to cover up the wrongdoings of the
heroes
and he pretty much acted exactly how he
wanted to now the show and series differ
in some ways
and in the source material the character
started feeling like he was having
blackouts
due to being unable to remember certain
events that he was seen doing
this eventually led to him believing
that he'd impregnated billy butch's wife
and depending on what version you
subscribed to she either died or went
into hiding
now in the show the two had an affair
whereas in the comics
homelander believes that he forced
himself on her but again
the blackouts made him question his
memories either way this caused a
rivalry between butcher and the
character
and in both the comic and series billy
was brought in by the cia to take the
company and homeland it down
now we don't know the exact direction
that the show is going in just yet
however from the way that things are
shaping up it does seem like they're
going to be following the comic arc very
loosely
with him slowly turning into a
full-blown murderer
in the comics homelander believed that
he was going insane and this emboldened
him to act more aggressively
and basically do whatever he wanted to
after he realized that ball would simply
use him up and then discard him when the
time was right
he decided to form an uprising of
superheroes that would take over the
world
homelander in the group killed those
that refused to join
and with the remaining supes he launched
an attack on the white house
this led to the death of the president
and butcher confronted him in the oval
office
joined by black noir it's here that we
got the book's big twist
and discovered that noir was actually a
clone of homelander
who'd been the one carrying out the
atrocities early on dressed as the
character he'd photographed himself
and had sent the easter homelander to
gaslight him into believing that he was
the one behind the crimes
homelander completely lost it and
realized that he'd been used not only by
vote
but also noir as well he went into a
full rage
but noir completely overpowered him and
killed the character
the biggest tragedy is that homelander
actually could have been a hero
but due to the power that he possessed
corrupting him he ended up going on a
darker path
which just rubs salt in the wounds of
his final defeat
in the end butcher killed noir and was
able to do this
because homelander had severely weakened
him i guess
i guess it's not the big darth vader
turn that a lot of people were expecting
but hey
in the end he was a true hero no
he wasn't really and what was and what
was with that breast milk
now we still don't know what the show
will be like and every day i go back and
forth over whether noir will be his
clone or not
in all of the promotional material they
stand in a very similar position to one
another
perhaps showing that they are indeed
duplicates however
the twist is so well known at this point
that it's actually difficult to not
stumble across it and i'm still in two
minds over whether it will be dropped
this way or not
i think the creative team behind the
series are unsure themselves
and for now they're just leaving things
ambiguous so they can decide when they
need to
in the comics homelanders says noir is
the person that he's known the longest
whereas in the show it's maeve and yeah
there's just tons of differences between
the two
and it's probably gonna go in any
direction still though
who knows ryan may not even be homeland
his son
and this would break the character even
further if the one person he actually
cared about
wasn't even his own anyway that's pretty
much everything you need to know about
homelander
and who knows i might even do an update
on this video down the line
as we learn more about the show's
counterpart make sure you let me know
your thoughts on the character below
and if you want something else to watch
then definitely check out our breakdown
of black noir
which is going to be linked at the end
we go over everything that you need to
know about the character
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more we're also giving
away a free copy of the christopher
nolan collection on the 30th of
september
and all you have to do to begin with the
chance of winning is like the video
subscribe to the channel and drop a
comment below
if you want to support us and get to see
content like this early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you could also come chat who's on the
discord server linked in the description
or heavy spoilers on twitter thanks for
making it until the end of the video
you've been the best i've been
definition i'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]